nope my favorite Christmas song is
Frosty the Snowman by the Ronettes good
one better O'Rourke so hot right now
the Texas Democrat may have lost his
long ish shot to oust Republican Texas
senator Ted Cruz in the 2018 midterm
elections but that hasn't stopped many
in the party from wishing and hoping and
wishing and hoping he decides to run for
president in 2020 good singing I know
and in late November a work acknowledged
that he is actually thinking about
running for president here's his quote
running for Senate I was one our percent
focused on
our campaign winning that race now that
that is no longer possible
you know we're thinking through a number
of things and
aye aye Amy and I made a decision not to
rule anything out
Amy in case you're wondering is
O'Rourke's wife but that's not the big
news here big news is that all works
we've made a decision not to rule
anything out rhetoric it's a major
change from what he was saying during
his campaign against Cruz like for
example this line from the day before
the 2018 election quote I will not be a
candidate for president in 2020 that's I
think as definitive as those sentences
get and quote except here's the thing
of course what O'Rourke is saying today
is the exact opposite of what he was
saying a few weeks back but he's right
to change his mind because a work should
absolutely 100% be running for the
Democratic presidential nomination in
two years time let me make the case and
I'll start making that case by quoting
the esteemed princess philosopher
Cinderella quote opportunity is not a
lengthy visitor Cindy says in into the
woods the mid-80s Stephen Sondheim
fairytale theme musical sigh Park yes I
am a fan of musical theater thank you
very much for asking now the point of
Cinderella's quote is simple moments
that matter in your life don't stick
around forever you need to seize them
ASAP or run the risk of missing them
which gets me back to O'Rourke he
started the 2018 election as a totally
unknown member of Congress from Texas he
ended that election as a national
democratic rock star now yes I am aware
that O'Rourke lost his race to Cruz I
kind of mentioned that above and that
again yes
losing Senate candidates are not usually
at the front of the line to run for
president but O'Rourke sauce was narrow
about two hundred thousand votes out of
more than eight million cast and as I
did say before that defeat has done
almost nothing to cool the heat around
the guy among the Democratic activist
community now that heat in political
terms means opportunity and it's an
opportunity that O'Rourke may never get
again here's why in January a work will
be out of a job he retired from his
House seat to run for the Senate which
means that his next
to run for a major statewide office in
Texas would be in 2020 against
Republican Senator John Cornyn the
Cornyn is a far less divisive politician
and Cruz and would be much harder to
beat and let's remember our work didn't
beat Cruz if our work passes on that
race his next next chance would be in
2022 when Republican governor Greg
Abbott would be up for a third term
now Abbott could be moving toward a
presidential race in 2024 by that point
so it is possible that the governor's
race would be open but even if open
series isn't any sure thing for O'Rourke
or candidly any Democrat in the state of
Texas so a right best chance and it's
not even that great a chance to win a
major office in Texas would be in 2022
and if he passes on the 2020
presidential race his next opportunity
to run for president wouldn't be yes
math until 2024 if a Democrat beats
Donald Trump in 2020 then a work would
have to wait until 2028 to run for
president now a rock is a young guy he's
46 as a 42 year old guy I reserve the
right to say that is still young but
politics is a fickle mistress and the
public has the attention span of a flea
four years in politics is forever think
about this time four years ago
Republicans had won another major
midterm victory Donald Trump's name
wasn't even on the long long long long
list of potential GOP presidential
candidates everyone assumed Hillary
Clinton would be President I mean
honestly looking back it feels like 40
years ago not four years ago right this
second battle worth is the hottest thing
in democratic politics he's touched a
nerve among Democrats in a way that no
one since a guy named Barack Obama has
done he's proven he can raise tens of
millions of dollars to fund a national
campaign now in four or even eight years
there will be a new hottest thing and
probably several more hottest things a
Roark will be a guy who almost caught
lightning in a bottle a few years back
out of office he won't have the platform
to inject himself into the national
debate he will do that thing that
politicians all fear the most disappear
if O'Rourke runs for president in 2020
he is I really think a top-five
contender for the nomination
no scenario either in Texas or
nationally where you will have that sort
of chance again always remember what
Cinderella said opportunity is not a
lady visitor and that is the point make
sure to check out brand-new episodes of
the point every Tuesday and Thursday